ننتقل الآن إلى قضية مروعة هنا في
المملكة المتحدة، ستقضي لوسي ليتبي،
القاتلة التسلسلية الأكثر إنتاجًا للأطفال في تاريخ بريطانيا الحديث،
بقية حياتها
خلف القضبان، حُكم على الممرضة
اليوم بالسجن مدى الحياة دون
إمكانية الإفراج المشروط يوم الجمعة من
محكمة مانشستر  وجدت أنها مذنبة
بقتل سبعة أطفال ومحاولة
قتل ستة آخرين في المستشفى حيث
كانت تعمل سانجيتا لال. قدمت لنا هذا التقرير.
وصلت لوسي ليتبي إلى المحكمة لمواجهة
جرائمها لكنها لن تواجه عائلات ضحاياها البالغة
من العمر 33 عامًا.  رفضت قاتلة الأطفال
ترك نفسها ورفضت الاستماع
إلى العائلات التي وصفت بشجاعة
ما أخذته منهم
والدة ليتبي، الضحية الأولى، وهو
صبي توأم قتلته في يونيو 2015،
قالت لم نكن نتخيل أبدًا أن
أغلى الأشياء في حياتنا
سيتم وضعها في مثل هذا الأذى في رعاية
ممرضة
وتحدثت أم أخرى لفتاة ولدت قبل الأوان أيضًا دعني أقتل
طفلها عندما كان عمرها يومين عن طريق
حقن الهواء في عروقها
ووصفت ما سمح لي بأخذه من
عائلتها وهو يمسك صغيرًا  تيدي بين
يديها قالت إن رماد ابنتها تم
دفنه في صندوق صغير في موعد ولادتها الفعلي
قالت ذراعي قلبي حياتي
شعرت بالفراغ المؤلم للغاية
وأم الطفل الرضيع الذي ترك
يُقتل شاركت كيف شعرت عندما كانت
لأول مرة  رأت طفلها،
كان الأمر لا يشبه أي شيء شهدته
من قبل، فرائحة
ابني البكر الصغير كانت تشمها، ومضت
لتقول كيف أنها لن
تنسى أبدًا لمسة يده، وكيف كانت
ترتدي يده وبصمات أقدامه كل يوم
قلادة حتى سمعت أن
لوسي ليتي قد تم القبض عليها لأنها
كانت ليتبي هي التي أخذت الأمير
لسنوات، ولم تستطع أن تحمل هذه الذكرى لابنها
حتى الآن بعد أن حصلت على
العدالة لطفلها،
دعني دائمًا أنكر كل تهمة
واجهتها بدلاً من ذلك.  ادعت أنها تعرضت
للتخويف من قبل الأطباء واستخدمت ككبش
فداء لسوء الرعاية في الوحدة
في محاكمة استمرت 10 أشهر واستغرقت
هيئة المحلفين أكثر من 110 ساعة للتوصل إلى
أحكامها، فهي مذنبة بقتل
سبعة أطفال ومحاولة
قتل ستة آخرين في  ما
وصفه القاضي بالهجمات القاسية المحسوبة
والساخرة أثناء إصدار الحكم،
خاطب المحكمة كما لو كانت في
قفص الاتهام، لقد تصرفت بطريقة
تتعارض تمامًا مع الغرائز الإنسانية الطبيعية المتمثلة في
تربية الأطفال ورعايتهم
وفي انتهاك جسيم للأمانة.  أن
جميع المواطنين يضعون في أولئك الذين يعملون في
المهن الطبية ورعاية
الأولاد التوأم يقولون أنهم
يقولون إن بعض الطرق تتحرك الآن دعهم
يحاولون قتل أحد أبنائهم عن طريق
تسميمهم بالأنسولين
وشقيقه عن طريق حقنه بالهواء الذي
يوفره  قليل من الخاتمة،
ليس تمامًا ولكن على الأقل قليلًا من
الخاتمة، حيث أنهم حصلوا على
الشخص المناسب وستتم معاقبتها
على ذلك، لكن ذلك لن يحقق العدالة
بغض النظر عما أزهقته من أرواح، فقد
حاولت قتل أطفال آخرين.  لذا،
أيًا كان الحكم الذي ستتلقاه، فلن
يكون كافيًا
اليوم، بالنسبة لبعض الآباء،
المرة الأولى التي شاركوا فيها مشاعرهم في
المستشفى على طول هذه الممرات عندما تعرض
أطفالهم للهجوم، وصفت إحدى الأمهات
كيف دخلت
لتقتل ابنها لكنها تركته  بمفردها
معها لأنها كانت ممرضة
ووثقت بها، شاركت هي وآخرون كيف
يعيشون الآن مع ذنبهم وكيف
أصيبوا بالصدمة لأن الشخص
الذي يثقون به لرعاية أطفالهم
خانهم بأكثر الطرق وحشية لكنها
استخدمتها  موقف يسمح لها بالتلاعب
بكل من حولها حتى تتمكن من
تنفيذ أعمالها السادية والحاقدة، وهي
أجنبية
تقضي الآن حكمًا بالسجن مدى الحياة على
قاتل متسلسل تعمد إلحاق
الألم بالأطفال الأكثر ضعفًا.